in other videos we had started talking
about the types of bonds that might form
between atoms of a given element for
example if you have two metals
forming a bond well you are going to
have a metallic bond
if you have
two non-metals
non-metals
engaged in some type of bonding activity
this is likely to be a covalent bond
and the general rule of thumb is if you
have one metal
one metal and
one non-metal
not one non-metal
that this is likely to be an ionic bond
these are the general rules of thumb
what i want to do in this video is to
better appreciate that bonding is really
more of a spectrum there are bonds and
we've talked about things like polar
covalent bonds that start to look a
little bit more and more ionic in nature
and so that's what we're going to talk
about in this video and think about it
in the context of electronegativity
just as a reminder we talk about
electronegativity in many videos but
this is the property of an atom that's
in a bond to hog electrons to want the
electron density to be closer to it for
the electron pairs to spend more time
around that particular atom so something
with a high electronegativity is going
to be greedier with the electrons than
something with a low electronegativity
we could think about the spectrum
between
at this end you have ionic
and at this end you have covalent
and one way to think about it is at the
extreme left end you don't have much
difference in electronegativities
both atoms that are participating in the
bond are roughly equal in how badly they
want the electrons while in an ionic
bond you have a very big difference in
electronegativities so much so that one
of the atoms swipes an electron from the
other so one way to think about it is
let me draw a little bit of an arrow
here so this is
increased
electro
negativity
difference as you go from left to right
and someplace in the middle or as as you
go from left to right you're becoming
more and more polar covalent so for
example if you have a bond between
oxygen and hydrogen these are both
non-metals so this will be a covalent
bond by our just our general rule of
thumb and actually the division between
metals and nonmetals i'm going to make
it right over here it's this blue line
is one division you could view although
things that straddle it are a little bit
more interesting but oxygen and hydrogen
are both non-metals but you have a
pretty big difference in
electronegativities this right over here
is electronegativity measured on a
pauling scale named after the famous
biologist in chemist linus pauling and
you can see on that scale oxygen is a
3.44 one of the most electronegative
atoms electronegativity trends we talked
about in other videos goes from bottom
left to top right the things at the top
right that are not the noble gases these
are the ones that really are greedy with
electrons and oxygen is one of the
greediest while hydrogen it's not not
electronegative but it's lower at 2.20
so in this scenario those electrons are
going to spend more time around the
oxygen if they spend an equal amount of
time that oxygen might be neutral but
since they're spending a little bit more
time here we'll say that has a partial
negative charge the greek lowercase
letter delta and on the hydrogen side
because the shared electrons are
spending more time around the oxygen
than around the hydrogen you would have
a partially positive charge right over
there and so this would be a polar
covalent bond maybe on the spectrum it
sits right over there depending on how
you want to how you view this scale
now the other question says okay this is
a spectrum between covalent and ionic
what about metallic
well metallic bonds are in general going
to be formed if you have two things that
are not so different in
electronegativity
and they both have reasonably low
electronegativities
so that's why things on the bottom left
right over here if you have two of these
forming bonds with each other somehow
that you're likely to have metallic
bonds and that makes sense because in
metallic bonds you have all the
electrons kind of mixing in in a shared
pool which gives some of the properties
like conductivity and so if you have a
lot of things that are fairly similar in
electronegativity and they're all low in
electronegativity they might be more
willing to share those valence electrons
in a communal pool